out
we'll leave them to work as it's getting
cleaned
but yo we are purchasing a kia
ev6
in order to take comma to the future of
electric
because environment does that make sense
ah
yo yo yo yo yo yo
what's up
oh it's leaving it's leaving i don't
know where it's going
it's leaving check it out
we bought an ev6 yo you guys you you
don't want to know how much i'm paying
for this thing
you don't want to know how much i'm
paying
what up bugsy
good to see you back
still got a subaru look it's going it's
going over here it's going to get
cleaned it's blue
we got a blue ev6
uh we're five grand five grand over msrp
is our is our markup
uh we called them all
some of them were doing even more
so uh we'll take it
we raised money for a reason
no no we're paying five over msrp
what else we got
yeah i believe we'll leave them why are
these all ev6s
oh they have a lot of them here
this silver one looked good
yeah yeah but this is the all-wheel
drive we don't want the all-wheel drive
useless
that silver does look good though
what do you guys think the silver
look at all of them
we got blue
oh this matte silver is really nice
looking though
nah but oh it doesn't have the white
trim okay i don't like the interior as
much all right all right i like that i
like that white trim interior
you think blue and red are the best
looking all right all right thank you
thank you
i see does this one have the white trim
interior
nah it's all black no no the interior is
so much nicer on ours
oh yo
all right so we're here at kia north
county in escondido
uh what are these things are these telly
rides
oh sorrento
um
so you know that we're splitting the
cars up we have gold cars silver cars
bronze cars uh no it's not all-wheel
drive
it's just rear wheel drive we are in
sunny southern california
what is this thing
nero do we want one of these
should we buy a neuro
what are these oh these are stingers oh
stupid gt line rear wheel drive hey
um but yeah no we bought an ev6 uh for a
bunch of reasons
one
um
it's got canfd
two
hyundai's are
we have two gold tier cars really our
gold tier cars are toyotas and hyundais
um hyundais have the torque
they have the longitudinal
uh this car has four corner radars
uh so we were doing tests today
where we were like can you drive the car
to taco bell with a joystick right so
can your joystick drive a car to taco
bell um remember as long as joystick
driving is okay as long as you're still
obeying comma safety model right
of course we got a gt line of course i
bought that hda2 we have the front
radars as well
um
so yeah we have hda2
my hope also
is that uh what is this one up here
ah wind all-wheel drive
what am i going to do with an all-wheel
drive
i'm in calvin california
um and the the rear wheel drive is uh
gets better mileage
is do you want to drive faster though
does your wheel drive have more
horsepower
toyotas are better quality than hyundai
i have some real doubts about that
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
how long are we keeping it for i don't
plan to get rid of it
i'm gonna think i'm gonna trade my
sonata i think i'm gonna be driving
around in the ev6
wow that thing that that delorean silver
though is very nice
wait the all-wheel drive is faster how
much faster should i go inside right now
and say we'll get the all-wheel drive
instead
225 horsepower now the other one's 225
horsepower too
this one's all-wheel drive
some of us are in financing right now
uh wait this is all-wheel drive what's
this one
there aren't many rear-wheeled
rear-wheel drive comma drift yeah right
i don't i like real drive cars which one
of these is
george you can't put chains on the tires
wait no no no this definitely doesn't
have a 320 horsepower motor
uh
this is all wheel drive it is 225.
and the last ev6 in a row they're all
all-wheel drive and they all have the
same motor
uh if it's faster it's only a tiny bit
faster i'm not sold
just because i can get more
more go power i guess not get more
horsepower 225 you know
but yo it's responsive it's got that low
end torque
um
yeah
comments on common body well
did you oh it's coming along nice it's
coming along nice
um
no silicon shortage for all-wheel drives
right
what charges does it use i don't even
know i've never owned an electric car
before but um you know we care about the
environment and we're going to the
future
three slims not happening
then there is going to be a rev in the
comma 3 but the rev is mostly just so we
can save money
and we can decide whether to pass that
savings on to you but the answer will
probably be to pass the profits on to us
what cars can make it a taco bell on a
joystick that's a great question no
nothing's 320 horsepower there's no cars
here that are 320 horsepower
um
this here is a gt line
all-wheel drive
and it's 225 horsepower
oh wait that's standard rear wheel drive
features oh my god it is 320 horsepower
oh i'm kind of sold
oh i'm kind of sold
look at this look they dupe you
they've the standard look at this here's
the standard gt line i'm sorry for ever
doubting you youtubers and here's the
all-wheel drive with 320 horsepower
[Applause]
all in 426 feet pound of torque oh my
god wait should we actually switch
am i buying the wrong car right now
should we switch to the all-wheel drive
oh
oh
all right well we're gonna go we're
gonna go alex isn't financing right now
should we switch do we want to switch
keep the blue though keep the blue
switch it's less than 4k more it's not
less than 4k more it's like
oh they want all-wheel drive yo
yo 320 horsepower it's pretty nice
that's pretty nice no no no no no no we
got to be responsible with money boys we
got to be responsible with money we're
buying the rear wheel drive automobile
we're buying a rear drive automobile but
when we buy the second one of these
we'll buy all-wheel drive wait alex you
want to switch
you're the one sitting there and
financing i don't know
i don't like the i don't like the uh
it is only three comma threes
oh
uh switch
switch to this silver
uh
does the business need 320 horsepower
that's right okay listen listen listen
if three of you buy comma threes right
now we can afford it
no
it's my yeah right i lose range it's
just i lose range
i lose range i lose range
same battery no same battery less range
because something's got to drive all the
all the extra horsepowers
silver all-wheel drive wait alex do you
want to switch can we actually switch
i don't like the seat as much either the
other seat has this nice white trim on
it and this one doesn't
but the silver does look nice
what's the benefit
yeah what's the benefit no that's a good
point the business does not need 320
horsepower
yo but they really
if that sticker was a little bit more
yeah yeah yeah keep the blue seems nicer
all right all right we're keeping the
blue we're keeping the blue we're going
with the rear wheel drive ev6
uh
yeah yeah the range the range is less
good
the range is less good with the
all-wheel drive also the all-wheel
drives are more common
you got one second alex
rear wheel drive
final answer
um
more tire you have to replace all the
tires spend the difference in tackle
valve now but
yo yo yo yo we are getting uh we're
getting an ev6 we are bringing comma
into the future and i'll tell you the
future is actually probably about 80 gas
cars 20 electric cars until we upgrade
our grid
um alex is in financing right now
purchasing this car
um
what horsepower does this have
i can't even tell you
sticking with blue we're sticking with
blue no i'm looking at the silver more i
like the blue it's also that car has
really nice as this white accent on the
seat
it's really nice
um no the kia ev is
uh look i don't care about the
environment you all know me
uh but i do care about nice stuff and
this car is nice electric is nice and
that's really how you have to do it
uh you like the silver one better alex
oh
no i don't know
i'm looking at it up close i think the
blue is the right choice
no but we don't buy evs because they
save the environment we buy evs because
they have low end torque and more
importantly
regenerative braking what maybe you pick
the ev6 over the ioniq 5
i like the styling on the i like the
styling on the uh
on the
uh alex we're not going with the
all-wheel drive
i liked the styling on the ev6 more
um
but yeah i mean it's the same platform
it's pretty much the same car
uh it's interior it's black it's black
with his white accent that's pretty good
uh let me go look at our car
oh it's out of detailing where'd it go
i think it might be around front
uh just comma three matter kia or
hyundai they're basically the same car
though the kia to buy access to the kia
thing is is i don't know i didn't buy
the kia one but the hyundai one is forty
dollars and the genesis one is a hundred
dollars i was looking at the tech infos
when am i going to show you the car well
where is it
where is my car
as soon as we buy it
if we wait around to buy it i don't know
um
we can look at these other cars
does it have the lockout honestly we
don't know
we don't know i am here to gamble
um if it has the lockout
uh alex says you don't need me anymore i
could go home no i want to drive the ev6
home
uh
sorrento
love the silver
uh is this gonna be my daily driver yeah
i don't know
we'll see it'll be around the office
no i like the blow why not look you got
i mean i'm i'm i'm tempted by the
horsepower you know i like the
horsepower but uh
you know
we'll stick with the blue
uh
you should you get a tesla with fsd or
comma three on a new used card look if
you're asking me that question bro
buy the tesla they'll have someone who's
gonna give you support
um
yeah we're looking into a firmware mod
for the sonata
uh you know i think the lockout is an
anti-safety feature i think the lockout
actually makes things less safe like
what kind of stupid system drops torque
at 90 degrees
uh so stupid that's not a safety feature
right like the less torque is generally
safer than more torque you can make the
argument that less torque can be less
safe in certain scenarios but overall
is this because the corolla can't get to
taco bell yes we were going to buy a
lexus es if the corolla could get to
taco bell but i think our future is
hyundai
um no no chevy bolts
toyotas yeah toyotas are going to add
security oh oh
the future is hyundai kia and genesis
of course i have a comment three in my
hyundai sonata just bought a comment now
go get the 320.
no no we're already it's already done
it's already done look how rare blue is
you see any other blue ones no it's
because blue is great it's actually
called yacht blue
um i've read this form thread
the the issue is steering wheel
torque no the issue with the sonata is
once you get the steering wheel to 90
degrees it stops applying steering
torque
um
so you know expect to see a lot more
love
for kia and hyundai
kia hyundai genesis this stuff's the
future of comma toyota is still the
future too honda is not the future if
you bought a honda you're not the future
um
[Music]
we were doing that we're doing this new
star system and the problem is the
hondas uh don't have torque they don't
have steering torque we can never ship
mods
so you know
uh
oh those white seats are nice look at
this car oh look at them white seats
it's pretty nice
um
ooh
the gv they make an electric gv70 i was
looking at the g80
and i just couldn't with the uh
i i didn't like the steering wheel i
thought it looked so ugly
like did they and that was like the top
comment on youtube like i was thinking
it before youtube yo so i wasn't like
influenced
who's honking
[Music]
going on
yacht blue
that's right
that's right yacht blue
uh
the worst part of any genesis is a
steering wheel it's such a terrible
steering wheel like i couldn't i
couldn't buy that car i couldn't be
happy oh they're honking just
honking solidarity
someone with an all-wheel drive socket
uh wait what's the via oh oh yeah i
heard there's some stupid like the
genesis tries to sound like a sports car
and plays sports car noises in your
stereo that's just disgusting
this is just i'm just disgusted by that
integrated comma 3 won't ever happen i
do like the uh what is wrong with honda
hondas don't have steering torque
honda's don't have steering torque how
much worse is the big model delay versus
master i just shipped an optimizer so if
you're on the comma 2
you're out of luck
but uh if you're on the comma 3 it runs
in 20 milliseconds which is only 6
milliseconds more than the old master
um
oh yeah wait can i disable the fake
noise on my on my ev6
um
should we go back to my sonata
see if it's still there uh what's
steering torque it's how much you can
turn the wheel
um ev6 does it have the 90 degree thing
honestly i don't know
uh
i don't know
[Music]
oh
i'm in the way of this parking spot
i'm gonna go chill in the sonata
um what killed the hopes for a potential
corroded cruel taco bell run low end
torque
it doesn't have torque on the low end
um
yo you guys want to go look at other
cars we can just walk across the street
you want to go with cadillac's
what's the ev6 the ev6 is kia's hottest
new car i had to pay 5k over sticker to
buy one
uh you can disable the fake noise sweet
we good we good how how we good like
we're getting the car soon
like like i can stay on youtube while we
get the car or we're good like we're
going to the next stage of financing
low end tour low speed torque sorry
sorry uh yeah yeah torque at low speeds
well i ship something to correct the 90
degree lockout well my real hope is that
it just doesn't have it
like how awesome would it be if it just
didn't have it
hmm
ah
no i don't stream my church anymore
um but yeah so let's check out the
sonata here
this is the comma sonata
here is our flagship product the comma
three
uh you guys can check it out you guys
can buy one
uh if you don't already have one i did a
test drive at the other dealership i
feel like i need to test out the other
one
um
oh i didn't realize open pilot laundry
oh
wait if i turn this off
does that work
oh that's awesome i think i think i
don't know if that's actually shipped
maybe we'll ship that to the hyundai
uh i think it's probably just because i
have a special uh mod the screen is
stunning on these things you don't want
to know how much i paid for it they're
over a hundred dollars
um let's see if there's updates oh did i
get any updates
oh the sim issue yeah basically um the
pink cell phone carrier canceled all the
unlimited plans so we're gonna be
switching to a blue cell phone carrier
um
yeah the blue cell phone carrier
it's registered to you no no no no no
you're taking the hyundai sonata home
i'm taking the ev6 home
uh
you can go on road here
yeah check it out we name the branch how
difficult will it be to remove the uh
the the the lockout i think we can do it
yeah i know they're they're the
uncarrier we're very upset so now we're
gonna have to pay per gigabyte with the
blue people
uh so yeah the pink people are out
um
alex's gonna steal my ev6
i'm gonna be driving home in this in
this in this sonata
it's like an ev6 it's just not ev
uh greg removed it on the palisade not
on the uh
on the sonata they're different that's
not as more security
uh but it's not a problem we can get
around it
all right guys
general comma questions is hyundai more
torque than toyota
it depends um
on silver one
all right well we'll open the floor up
to general common questions and then
we'll stop the stream
uh unless we're gonna get the car soon
alex we're gonna get the car soon or is
there like 17 more paperworks because
i'm sure
youtube would love to see the car
up close where we can turn off the vass
um
[Music]
so yeah if you have a comma two we're
canceling comma two prime
uh you're gonna have to
yeah either get your own sim card and
buy prime light or not a prime
uh no there's no support for german cars
because of flex ray um is comma on a
yearly hardware release like the cell
phone industry not quite yearly
um think about i don't know what yes
means think about it more like uh
18 months
to two years but we don't do major
refreshes right so you can look like
like the eon gold and the comma two were
quite similar
um
we're going to be on the comma three
platform so the eon the eon gold the neo
the eon the eon gold and the comma two
were all basically the same platform so
the next the next three hardware devices
from comma well the next two are going
to be on the same platform as the comma
three
um
so yeah comma threes are pretty future
proof we were even talking about going
forward if we ever wanted to change the
camera configuration again and the
answer might be no like we have 360
360 plus the radars that are in the ev6
should be enough
uh you're happy with the 90 degree
lockout now eight newton meters is
dangerous yeah i know the key is nice
right you got the key wait let's go
let's go we got to show the youtubers
the car
um more engineers in rotterdam yeah
we're hiring and rotterdam if you want
to go work there
uh absolutely
oh she's grabbing the car from the back
oh nice
nice i can't believe we're already
through all the stuff
um
palisade has the lockout now eight
newton meters is uh you can't do that
all the time there's some serious safety
issues there
uh
it's also it's interesting how they
measure torque like it's a torque before
the application or torque after but the
93 lockout is an anti-safety feature and
we could totally remove it uh you wish i
started twitch again that's good for you
um how is the current failure
reliability rate
thirty percent no
no no the comma three failure rate is is
is we posted it it's like seven percent
or something and falling
um the early ones had some issues but
all the common threes are under warranty
uh the other difference between the
three and the two
is we have uh
we have the parts store for the comma
three so if your comma three does break
out of warranty it's not like you have
to buy a new one like you can fix it
with the parts
um but the reliability seems to be about
five times better than the comma twos
uh we're putting a lot more effort too
into tracking down all the failures on
the comma threes oh just pre-order comma
body i don't think we have many more of
those pre-orders left
um current price for comma three plus
amount it's 21.99 for the base model and
then 200 bucks it's you can buy three
comma threes and still not be able to
afford the difference between the rear
wheel drive and the ore wheel drive
all-wheel drive mazda long i'm excited
about mazel i'm actually very excited
about the cx-5 i think the cx-5 has the
potential to be a gold car
it's on all of them it's one of the top
25 cars sold in america
is the remove unreleasable
it's more releasable than the honda mods
it's more releasable than the honda mods
i'll say that uh the comma two updates
for the comma two stop in june
uh
eta on anta and long the new models look
a lot better
uh the new models look the new models
are nice
um we we found some some some bugs
uh promotions uh i mean we do raises
about every year
i don't know like titles are meaningless
you can have whatever title you want we
used to give people titles just because
like titles are cheap but like
you know like there's a few like major
promotions i mean like harold was
promoted to cto
uh are we still profitable hell yeah of
course um yeah yeah we are we are very
profitable in fact we raised 10 million
dollars and our bank account is still
above 10 million dollars so we're not
spending enough money and i've been
saying this we've got to spend more
money so here we are you see i can't
even bring myself to buy the all-wheel
drive um end-to-end teaser videos we're
not doing any more of those i know they
were nice but uh
you know what do they do
you'll get it when you get it it's good
um
[Music]
we need
uh yo if you could do like like hardcore
infrastructure like you're good at like
like we have to like refactor
basically we need our pipeline to go
faster if you okay
i'll explain one of the problems why
models are taking a long time we have a
firm
um models are taking a long time because
we have a data center that's kind of
small
and
everything's taking too long to run now
we have big plans to build a new data
center but we don't have enough power to
run the data center
uh
so yeah things are a little bit slow but
if you are looking uh to come work here
and you're great at infrastructure is
that my car did i just see my car go by
where's my car
this is my car
where's it going
are we ready
wanna show them the key
yes thank you
do you wanna say you want a sonata key
check it out boys check it out
i'm sorry did it lock
uh no
rotterdam is only a software development
house rotterdam does not ship any
hardware
great
thank you
do you want to come do you want to come
say hi to twitches or checking out our
new all right
yo yo yo yo check it out yes we're still
looking for a new office
uh we are definitely still looking for a
new office
yo i mean really what i liked and why we
couldn't switch the silver is i love
these white accents on the seat and none
of the silver had it
yeah they test the door handle yeah
oh it's locked
look at this thing
is this a spaceship or or what
right
thank you well we're gonna have to leave
the youtubers while i drive but we can
drive around the parking lot with
youtubers
yeah yeah
drive in the parking lot for a second
yeah yeah yo
yo
like look at this thing guys look at
this look at this look at this
oh wait they're capacitive
look at this empty space here
how sick you can't really see it on the
how sick is that yo you know what we're
making better though by 320 horsepower
if i knew the all-wheel drive had 50
more horsepower i would have considered
it more and then not gone with it but i
would have considered it more concealed
look look someone finally built a
responsiveness it's so quiet the only
one who can build software oh and
apparently the noise that it does make
is fake you can turn it off in settings
they have a fake noise mode
like look at this wheel you know you
know why i couldn't find i looked at a
genesis g80 i couldn't buy it
the wheel looked disgusting
really yeah
what did what did it look like it looked
like an old man wheel
look at this
i love this look at this accent like
this is even more pronounced than the
one on the sonata oh interesting the
shape yeah the shape
huh
what what
is this car fully charged no she said it
only has 100 miles on it
when we walked in she said she
prioritized getting it cleaned
so we could get out of here on time we
only paid five grand over sticker though
right correct
wait wait will you see these things go
for 20 over sticker
now we think these are gonna be like the
uh the rav4 primes
it's not even yelling at me for having
no seat belt on yeah i know because it's
chill i love this car i love this car
wait but where are we going to go charge
it we'll take it to l.a i hear they have
chargers there alex we can't make it
it's going to go to your house
yeah i don't have charges in my house
you do yeah but i can't park in those
spots they're for other people
they have numbers let's go to the lot
the dgs lot all right
you can pay i think you have to sign up
with the company great
you want to take this car i don't want
it anymore no i want to drive it home i
want to just drive also we could plug it
into the office briefly we could plug
into the office yeah yo it's beautiful
guys
this is the future of comma i'm gonna
stick a comma three right there you're
gonna sit back you're gonna chill does
it have creep
can i turn it off can i turn creep off
yeah we got a kia i hope i can turn can
i turn creep off do you guys know
creep just upsets me on electric cars
you know creep
no
you know that tlc song
no no when you take your foot off the
gas it goes oh
um and like there's no actual when you
put off the break it goes it rolls
forward there's no actual reason for
this
it is charged car or train models
uh
yeah
wait active sound design provides a
driving sound for evs off
why would anybody want this are you
showing me using the thing
yeah all right um
smart regeneration system
yeah wait can i turn creep off
i feel like you can't turn creep off on
this car
we have to put it in secret mode how do
i put the konami code in
why would i want that
wait do you want to ask your building if
we can get one of those spots
i don't know is this going to be the car
drive now or am i going to stay with the
sonata
i said
that's a stupid question do you really
think i'm driving this of course i do
maybe electric cars are kind of
inconvenient
now the question is does it have a 90
degree steering lockout
hda2 is crazy too
a ton of evs don't let you but you have
a brake hold
oh i have a brake hold
hey alex we do read the chat
wait wait wait
i will be so offended turn on auto hold
to turn off creep oh turn on auto hold
to turn off creep okay oh no
okay good well that's it
okay good
if it is actually applying both the
brakes and the gas right now i'm so
offended
you know what i mean like it could be
doing that
what car this is the kia ev6
gtl version
yeah
i think it actually does use the breaks
in the mold
you can see all the details
what is this
oh it's um
the wireless charger so nice yeah just
put your phone down here i think it
works it doesn't work one has a case on
it
mine works with the gym tan laundry
that's right
oh my god she's a real beauty
okay
i do have great nails for touching cars
[Music]
oh did you did you reveal our temporary
license plate number it's gonna it's
gonna be a huge problem isn't it
they already do
okay
george in the car our wonderful sales
lady christina
did you make a drive already
i'm sure it does but george probably
needs to charge his phone too
i assure you george showered
recently
[Music]
i think those under lights are illegal
in california
don't quote me on that yeah
look at the lights in the front
there's settings inside there that you
can basically hit while you're really
okay so the black one has like a texture
trim here
which i really liked but it was very
yeah i'm glad you distinctive like the
blue we were really um unsure about it
earlier today all of that stuff right
now when you go down the window i'll try
to make it pretty quick thanks
in case you guys ever get locked out of
that car there's a key
back here
you're getting the whole experience now
guys
didn't know we were streaming i would
have brought the handhold thing
george is 5 10.
this is the kia ev6 gtl
you guys want to see what it's like to
be in the back
me too
back here
look at the white trim sonata has most
of these features on there as well you
got the blind spot collision avoidance
assist anything that doesn't fit
actually
um so the forward collision avoidance
assist if it notices anything in front
of you um in front of your senses it's
going to go ahead and almost like bucket
seats
not until you hit the gas again a little
bit more girls got that new car smell
blind spot collision avoidance is this
it detects the car next to me and you're
trying to turn into that right lane
torch has no idea when any of this stuff
is back over
um but you can go ahead and turn that
off inside the settings
you don't want any of those features on
okay
like the lights in the back have a
button
it's gonna do the same thing as a
forward collision just in the back so if
it detects anybody about to walk by it's
gonna be ev6 gtl keeping assist and lane
following assist you're gonna find that
on your steering wheel it's a little car
on the road no we got a center
can't see it sorry guys
there is the sunroof
see how we open it though you got the
dual panoramic with displays and the
navigation
right here in the car
which i do want you to connect that
that's going to go ahead and um
basically just make an emergency 911
call for you in case your airbags never
go they can't have artists
oh look how nice the door details are on
on this car because not only does it
stop and go for you um if you turn on
your blinker to go into the right lane
you literally don't have to switch it'll
switch for you on the gt1 yeah i thought
that was super cool
um dual zone automatic climate control
the smart power tailgate wireless phone
charger vegan leather
seating seated ventilated front seats
power adjusted driver's seat no idea
alert you can turn that off too if you
don't ever carry passengers but a lot of
boxes so it's not constantly telling you
um
outside mirrors with the turn signals
you got the towing package pre-wiring in
here so if you didn't want to add that
in there all you need is the accessory
okay
you got 10-year 100 000 on the
powertrain just like i think hyundai has
that and then you also have it on the
battery
and then you have five years sixty
thousand on roadside assistance
um pop
pop out outside door handles believe it
or not put on the wind you have to talk
about yourself
[Music]
you got the wide sunroof in here the
auto dimming rear view mirror with the
home link um it's very easy to set that
up you literally have a qr reader that
can show you how to set that up okay
remote smart parking assist showed you
how to use that blind spot view monitor
basically the eagle eye cam
parking collision avoiding persistent
rubber smart piece control with the
machine learning
and then the forward collision avoidance
highway driving assist too and then you
got the um floor mats and then locked in
here as well
is there any questions you have
regarding the car the only thing is this
looks like there was a sticker on the
back guys it has machine learning
but what this was
[Laughter]
uh
george the people want to see the sun
touch base on everything the people want
to see the sun right now
the team also wants to know what machine
learning is machine learning
it's
the most advanced cruise control that
you have on any car right now um it's
basically going to switch lanes for you
versus just reducing the speed and
speeding up
[Music]
wow
pretty nice pretty nice yeah like a wide
angle view on here
yeah yeah yeah huh
okay you can use the apple carplay or
android auto in here but because you do
have the navigation in here um you will
have to plug it into the usb port down
there in order to use it in the car okay
got it do you have auto hold in any of
your cars i've just used all the holes
yeah i was excited that it doesn't uh i
hate when the electric cars creep
there's no reason for them to do it
uh so yeah it turns it off
you got the wireless phone charger right
underneath your hand right there okay
um
the phone charger
all doors need to be closed really you
can't charge your phone when the doors
open
i don't know why but yeah
they said they're scared to let a
machine drive the
sit car the backseat and let him hit the
cruise control
i don't know you guys are driving a
different car
yeah yeah yeah it's really neat when you
use it it's really neat
it makes it worth it no i mean when we
when i test drove this car at the other
dealership that was the only thing i
checked out yeah the news control i
think was good yeah yeah they're they're
you know they're doing it really well i
think that uh yonder and kia have a have
a bright future yeah uh you know really
like you hear all this stuff evs gm and
ford i don't know anyone with a gm and
f4 tv like i don't want to bolt yeah so
i got a bolt forty thousand dollar car
and it had uh manual seats
i used to work for charlotte when those
first came out in 2016. i sat in the car
for 30 seconds and i'm like there's no
way i'd ever buy this
yeah yeah yeah really all right your
phone battery's dying you may actually
need to plug it in i'll use the
convenient wireless charger
you want
okay cool
great
let me say bye to the people
are we done we're done great thank you
very much both keys i have both keys yes
i do thank you so much thank you we're
so excited you're really proud yeah yeah
thank you you're making them move so
quickly
thank you guys
thank you
all right
yeah i'll see you back at the office
show the sunroom
bye youtube
goodbye
thank you all
can fd port coming soon i mean yeah it's
gonna be our first canon fd car
level five let's go
level five let's go
bye